I've set up I pulled out all the
important information so that I'm not
completing it with all the other stuff
in the question that's irrelevant right
so I've pulled out I've got two
locations I've got a departure time and
an arrival time I've also noted the days
of the departure in the arrival time
because they were faster in a little bit
later and then I thought about well okay
what question are they asking and
therefore what information is relevant
the first question is about time
difference if all you're picking out is
the time difference between two
locations you've got latitude and
longitude but only one of them is
important which one only longitudes
right we know that if you've got two
places on the same Marini of longitude
it doesn't matter how far north or south
you are of the Equator there will be the
same time so I can actually ignore these
guys for the rest of the question these
are the things that matter so you can
see in order to work out a time
difference I first have to work out a
longer to difference the way that I've
gone about it is I've remembered that
for each one of these degrees of
difference each degree represents four
minutes if I go so far before I get that
amount of time and I've divided by sixty
to be able to work out in hours and
minutes but I will mention just like at
the beginning if we're thinking about 24
hours and 360 degrees of rotation then
each hour because that's where I'm going
to go each hour is 50 degrees of
longitude so you know how I multiplied
by four and then I divided by 15 I
haven't written it but that's what I've
done okay I'm sorry divided by 60 rather
because that's how many minutes there
are in an hour 1 multiplied by 4 and
dividing by 15 is the same as going from
this number and just keep on saying 15
multiplying by 4 and dividing by 16 is
the same as taking this number and
dividing by 15 and if you want you can
get your calculator to 139 divided by 15
and you'll get 9.2
dude in something-something coming okay
and that's the number of hours remember
you can hit that degrees minutes seconds
button and it will convert you to this
no approximation required cool so we've
got a time difference between the two
cities therefore the next question says
calculate the time in Sydney when the
plane left Rome so what they tried to
lead us to what is let's forget about
Rome time let's think about everything
in terms of Sydney time because you know
we're also been the center of the world
so have a look at the way that I have
formatted this in here and again on your
working out please communicate what
you're doing you're working at Sydney
time they just start writing down
sometimes and adding and subtracting
things tell me what you're working out
I've also noted the day even though in
this case the time difference that we
add doesn't actually change the day that
we're on but it Kristin could have
Justin easily have done that if this was
26 minutes instead of 16 minutes there
did it be on Monday you know whatever
1206 a.m. on a Monday morning okay
so I've murdered the time and the day
and he comes the tricky part
what's the flight time that's that's the
question total flight time so I want to
show you what my working looks like and
then explain it this actually is the
last thing that I wrote I should have
put it at the end so I'll move it in a
minute or a second last this diagram
here is the important part and you don't
have to draw a diagram to do this part
successfully I just think it's a lot
easier so you don't get twisted in your
head when do I add subtract what am I
missing in here is a 12 or 24 hours
those kinds of things in terms of Sydney
time because that's what part 2 just did
it got everything in Sydney time I'm
leaving worm at this time on this day
and I'm arriving at this time on this
day and there's Sunday then Monday then
Tuesday so what I've worked out is for
Asia is three days how many minutes and
hours are there it only takes four
minutes to get out of Sunday because
you're at 11:56 p.m. the entirety of
Monday is included in this
departure arrival time so I've put down
24 hours and then on Tuesday morning
1:15 a.m. so one hour and 15 minutes
have passed on that day so if you take
all of that the time between a rather
departure is that that's the Sun okay
right they've asked for flight time
flight time not just what was the
difference between walking onto the
plane and off the final claim so
therefore I've subtracted the six hours
that were included in that layover and
that's what gives you your final answer